sallie plan is not the commonplace sight
on CBS she's a former Washington Post
reporter and we're very glad to have her
indeed you know the first day I come on
television I start out with a sore
throat and a fever and and now back to
you here's well there's what I have
fever is that set look at Sally Quentin
Hughes rugs
she made Sally Queen made history as the
first woman to anchor at CBS News
Morning Show in August 1973 after she
left CBS Quinn returned to a successful
print career at the Washington Post it's
funny to see you and he was right
because he said he liked you because you
were meaner than a junkyard dog that is
where she met her late husband Ben
Bradley he was opposed legendary editor
during the Watergate era Quinn's new
book is called finding magic a spiritual
memoir it detailed their marriage and
other defining moments that shaped her
beliefs sally quinn joins us now welcome
back to cBS well thank you queasy
driving up I must say as a longtime
friend of Sally that Ben Bradley was the
guy that every women every woman fell in
love with and every man wanted to be so
this is a wonderful sense of
relationship that you tell us all about
but what's interesting about you is I
knew about faith I didn't know about
hexes I didn't know about premonitions I
didn't know about all that other stuff
magic included well you know I and when
I started writing this book it was
because I had I had been an atheist and
started a religion website at the
Washington Post which already was sort
of a weird combination and I started
studying religion and it became clear to
me that all religion is magic and I had
been brought up in the south where you
know the the Scottish Presbyterian
stones and the ghosts and psychic
phenomena and moudou and all of that was
sort of part of my imbedded religion as
well as being a Christian and believing
in God and believing in Jesus I became
an atheist when my father liberated
Dachau and took pictures and I saw the
scrapbooks and I couldn't believe that
God had
this happened and that I was four years
old this is in World War two that I
became an atheist but as I started
studying religion it became clear to me
that it's that faith is really all about
magic and whatever you believe nobody
knows my favorite bumper sticker is I
don't know and you don't either and and
and so that magic and all of the things
that go along with magic are just
another name for whatever faith you
might have or whatever religion you
might have and that that I respect
they're all just as legitimate as the
others even institutional religions or
magic or you when you talk about
astrology or hexes or all that I mean
they're people billions of people all
over the world who believe in these
things and we don't and and we respect
them if we look at them and their
culture but then you bring it into our
culture and it looks very different you
grew up in a military family as you
mentioned your parents were of Scottish
descent and Presbyterian Christian
background but how did you learn
buddhu and who did you place hexes on
well I when I'm growing up in the south
and we had as I said that the Scottish
Presbyterian but also the staff in the
house were black Christians who went to
Baptist Church but then they would
practice voodoo on the side the way you
learned voodoo so I did learn voodoo and
you know it's the kind of thing where it
should we be nervous
[Music]
you go thumbs up we'll see how it goes
you say that you put voodoo some spells
on people three of them you know you
know and they did not have a pleasant
end so hey that's what I'm saying
yeah well there did yes this is true
oh I'm just understanding but I mean it
is very you know you're raising very
good points about what happened it's
very interesting I want you to make you
sound like you're cuckoo for cocoa puffs
but if you do raise some very
interesting things in the book I'm
fascinated with Charlie saying about Ben
Bradlee that you know he was a man
men want that women wanted and men
wanted to be but let's talk about you
miss Sally the word is you could have
had any man you wanted and they said
they used to vary demands private parts
if you wanted it you got it that you
went after the boss and I'm trying to
think if I went after les Moonves Orion
Keijo they would have me carted off to
the minute institution but you wouldn't
after Ben Bradlee and got this in mind
no no mrs. K Joe and mrs. Munez
definitely not but it seems like in the
book you went after Ben Bradlee the two
of you had a mutual love and connection
like no other and I'm very fascinated
he went after me actually I had I fell
in love with him and realized that it
wasn't gonna work because he was married
and had children and so I older I and he
was 20 years older so I accepted a job
as the first anchor woman in America
right here at CBS News let me just
understand began with Ben mm-hmm fling
began with Ben with Ben yes yes and I
read I was writing love notes to him but
anonymous and he didn't get it he didn't
get it you talk about being on a plane
next time on and try this technique
there was turbulence yes you grabbed his
thigh and you said you didn't let go
even after the turbulence ended but
there was there was a there was a
connection clearly between the doing I
am gonna try by the way he did not take
my hand but but it's very sweet I mean
he's no longer with us he had dementia
and you talk about when someone loves
you the way they say their name out of
their mouth is different and that the
way he said your name toward the end was
your your name no longer felt safe in
his mouth it's very sweet story well
well I say that yes when when you love
someone your name feel safe in their
mouth when someone loves you and and
there was a moment when Ben started
getting dementia where he his
personality changed he became somewhat
hostile and we had to get throughout
five minutes automatic breaks yes
and and so but in the end it was you
know it was the last two years of his
life where he had dementia loser